[SOLIDARITY LANES]
[UKRAINE USED TO GROW ENOUGH FOOD]
[TO FEED 400 MILLION PEOPLE]
[RUSSIA'S UNPROVOKED INVASION]
[BLOCKADED
UKRAINIAN BLACK SEA PORTS]
[FOOD SHIPMENTS STOPPED]
[EXPOSING MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE WORLDWIDE]
[TO THE RISK OF HUNGER]
[THE EUROPEAN UNION]
[TOGETHER WITH UKRAINE
AND THE REPUBLIC OF MOLDOVA]
[HAVE SET UP THE SOLIDARITY LANES]
[TO OPEN
ALTERNATIVE TRANSPORT ROUTES]
[THE SOLIDARITY LANES
HELPED EXPORT]
[OVER 15 MILLION TONNES
OF UKRAINIAN GRAIN SO FAR]
[THIS HELPS PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE]
[AND REDUCE
THE PRICE OF FOOD WORLDWIDE]
[WITH OUR PARTNERS
WE ARE NOW MOBILISING]
[1 BILLION EUROS
TO BOOST THE SOLIDARITY LANES]
[TOGETHER WE HELP INCREASE
GLOBAL FOOD SECURITY]
[AND PROVIDE A LIFELINE
FOR UKRAINE'S ECONOMY]
[SOLIDARITY LANES]